so Donald Trump's been caught lying once
again but this time it's not about which
porn star he had sex with and paid off
this time it's about more serious issues
including our relationships with Saudi
Arabia with what's going on with gas
prices and it's a very very strange
series of lies it started with Donald
Trump claiming last week that he called
up OPEC which is a fourteen country
organization related to oil and oil
prices and it's a really important
organization when it comes to the sort
of status quo of our use of fossil fuels
now obviously I would like to get to a
place where OPEC is irrelevant but
there's no denying that right now OPEC
is relevant and Trump claimed that he
called OPEC and said you've got to bring
prices down when OPEC was asked about
this they said Trump didn't call us we
haven't spoken to Trump Trump then said
well I spoke to Saudi Arabia about
increasing the oil supply and then Saudi
Arabia likewise said no he didn't and
this is yet another one of these
examples of malignant weaponized
narcissism combined with compulsive
lying Trump was on the tarmac Friday
about to fly - I believe the NRA rally
and Ra meeting or whatever and he said
maybe it was Saturday and he said quote
the gasoline prices are coming down I
called up OPEC I said you've got to
bring them down you've got to bring them
down and gasolines coming down this was
denied by OPEC - The Wall Street Journal
so what does Trump do he doubles down on
it with another lie tweeting quote spoke
to Saudi Arabia and others about the
increasing oil flow all are in agreement
the california tax on gasoline is
causing big problems on pricing for that
state speak to your governor about
reducing economic numbers 3.2 GDP for
what is often worst quarter
looking good so at this point it was
sort of like conceivably possible if we
give Trump the benefit of the doubt and
at this point I'm not sure why we would
because he lies all the time but imagine
we give Trump the benefit of the doubt
maybe what Trump meant when he said he
spoke to OPEC is he talked to OPEC
members like Saudi Arabia which he then
clarified in his tweet but then we heard
from Saudi Arabia that Trump also didn't
speak to the Saudi Energy Minister he
didn't speak to the crown prince he
didn't speak to the Venezuelan oil
minister who right now is the OPEC
president OPIC rotates who the president
is he didn't speak to the OPEC
secretary-general so applying our
version of Occam's razor to trump we
call it Trump's razor when looking to
explain Trump's behavior you err on the
side of the stupidest possible
explanation if that's that he just made
it all up and none of it is true then we
go with that and in this particular case
I think that that is the most likely
explanation the lies are relentless ten
thousand people were at my rally well
the fire department says six thousand is
the capacity and that there were not
more than six thousand people I spoke to
the president of Puerto Rico well you're
the president of Puerto Rico who is it
exactly that you spoke to and the really
important thing for our purposes here is
that Trump made this up but oil prices
still dropped after he said it and there
are some people on the right if you look
online who are saying Trump's brilliant
it wasn't true that he talked to OPEC it
wasn't true that he talked to Saudi
Arabia or whoever but Trump got us lower
prices by saying that he did and it's
genius that's not how things work okay
every time you do that you create a debt
on the other side of the ledger right
Trump lies the lies have a real
immediate impact on the world before we
find out that they're lies and then it
falls apart and at some point that has
an impact those are not lies that you
can tell it's sort of like burning the
candle on both sides I guess you would
say and it's reasonable to mention again
that Trump blaming California for Enki
increased gas prices that's not true all
of these specific things that Trump is
saying aren't true but we really need to
be having a totally different
conversation which is rather than trying
to lower gas prices by calling OPEC or
calling Saudi Arabia we should be
working feverishly like it's an emerge
because it actually is to end our
dependence on petroleum anyway but
that's like three levels removed from
where Trump is operating and it's
probably not reasonable to think that
that's something he's going to be
working on but once again weaponized
ignorant narcissistic compulsive lying
and it's having a real-world impact